So how did you break up the UI
into smaller components?
Well, you might've thought that
this could be two columns.
But then it would be hard to
position the elements here.
You could center them vertically
within the height of the screen.
But it wouldn't necessarily line up
with the temperature views on the left
hand side.
Instead this looks more like
a horizontal linear layout.
Then the rest of the elements could
be laid out by using a vertical
linear layout.
The vertical linear layout
would have six children.
The third element would be a horizontal
linear layout composed of two children.
The first would be another vertical
linear layout with these two text views
and the second element would be another
vertical linear layout composed of.
These two elements.
To make the contents of the whole
screen vertically scrollable
we put it inside a scroll view.
Using a list view her would be overkill
because we don't need to scale
to an infinite number of item and
we don't need recycling.
There's a fixed number of
fields on the screen so
the scroll view is the perfect choice.
I can show you our implementation for
the fragment detail XML layout.
We hardcoded some data in the layout.
So that it would show up as
a preview in the Design pane.
At the root of the view hierarchy,
we have a ScrollView.
ScrollViews can only have max one child.
So we set that to be
the vertical LinearLayout.
Inside of this layout, we have
a TextView for the day of the week.
The calendar date and
then a horizontal linear layout.
This is followed by
the humidity text view,
wind text view, and pressure text view.
In the XMO code we see the scroll
view with the child linear layout.
We give it some padding of 16 dips so
that the content is not flesh up
against the edge of the screen.
Then we see the text views followed
by the horizontal linear layout.
We specify layout margin top of 16 dip
to give it some more space from
the bottom of this text view.
Within this horizontal linear layout
we have one vertical linear layout.
Which has a width of 0 and
a weight of 1, and
another linear layout with
a width of 0 and a weight of 1.
That means that both of these
children have equal width.
For this linear layout, we specify
gravity to be center horizontal.
That means that the contents inside
of it will be centered horizontally.
Which includes the icon as well
as the forecast text view.
Lastly we have the remaining text
views for the other weather details.
When the layout looks good,
we update the detail fragment.
At this point,
we also move it into its own file.
In the unload finish method,
we used to have a find view by
ID call to find the text view.
Now that the detail fragment
has a lot more views
we don't want to continue adding even
more fine view by ID calls here.
Because it will have to traverse
the view hierarchy every time that
the loader refreshes.
Instead we modify the on create method.
Once the fragment is
inflated we go ahead and
find a reference to all the views
we are going to need later on.
We store these views as member
variables of the class,
which is why the name
starts with the letter m.
In the on create loader method we
make sure that the projection for
our content provider query contains
all the information that we need.
It's declared at the top of the file.
Before we had it called
forecast columns, but
we just renamed it to detail columns.
And we also added some more columns
because now we're displaying more
information on the screen.
Then in the onLoadFinished method we get
a cursor back with the data we need.
We read the weather
condition ID from the cursor
because we're going to need it to
determine which image to display but for
now we can use a place order icon.
We continue reading from the cursor
to get the date, the description and
the other fields.
To format the data properly for the user
we also copied over the strings and
the utility method from the gist.